- [Mark] How many young boys
do you think you've had fun with?
- Oh...
- Well, there's an old saying,
as many dicks that were put in me,
if they were sticking out,
I'd look like a porcupine.
That's how many.
- [Mark] All right, Frankie.
- [Frankie] Yes, sir?
- [Mark] Frankie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Frankie] Cleveland, Ohio.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
Did you have both of your
parents when you were young?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- Exciting, for a person who knew
he was gay at the age of 11 or 12
in a time when that wasn't right.
And I had, let's start the story,
I had a mother who had a boyfriend
while my father was alive,
but I don't think my father cared
'cause he was, like, 24
years older than my mother.
When my mother used to
go with her boyfriend,
I used to lay next to her
while he was having sex with my mother,
and I quite didn't know
what all that was about
until I got older and
started hearing sounds
that I heard when I was a kid.
Then, when I got older, about 11 or 12,
I started paying for guys in my school,
$5 here, $8 there,
and one of the guys told on me,
and I think I was the
very first sex offender
to ever be arrested for that.
Matter of fact, I had,
I'll never forget it,
a black judge, her last name was Kennedy,
this is in Cleveland, Ohio.
I was in the papers, front page.
"Cleveland Press" and "The
Cleveland Plain Dealer."
I'm sure if you looked in
the archives, I'd be there.
Anyway, judge gave me a year probation.
I had to spend two
summers on an Amish farm.
That was my sentence, and
I think I was 11 or 12.
And then nothing happened
until I got into my 30s
and a hustler came up to me
and he was, like, 16 years old,
and I paid it,
and I paid the price.
I did five years house arrest
and all that good stuff,
group and everything.
And then about four or five,
in 2003, I picked up a gentlemen.
I came home from the bar
a little drunk, high.
He was 13.
I guess I wasn't really looking at age.
I didn't ask how old
he was, took him home.
Well, there was a whole thing before that.
He lied to me, he told me that he was
waiting for his brother to
pick him up from Tarpon Springs
and this and that, so I took him home.
I said, "Well, why don't
you stay at my place?"
One thing led to another,
dirty movie, and then sex.
Then I found out the next day when he
knocked on my door after
school that, he told me,
"If you don't buy me a carton
of cigarettes, I'm gonna tell."
And I said, "Tell, tell what?"
He said, "I'm 13 years old."
So for weeks I bought him a
carton of cigarettes every week,
'til finally, I ain't doing this anymore.
So a couple of months later,
I got arrested for that
and spent eight and a
half years in prison.
I'm not gonna say I learned my lesson
because everybody says
they learned their lesson.
I know I'm not gonna do that again.
I'm 74 years old, my
sex life is over with.
I have no feelings for
that anymore with anybody.
I just wanna live my life out
and have no more of this hell.
Because if you go out
there and do something
that you shouldn't do
with an underage person,
it is hell afterwards.
They say, "Well, I've done my time."
No, you haven't done your time.
Your time starts after
you get out of prison.
That's when your time starts.
- [Mark] And what do you mean by that?
- When I'm in a store,
if a kid comes up to me,
I'm shy away.
I shy away, 'cause I don't want,
it just makes me shy away.
It scares me to death.
You never know who's watching
you and I just shy away.
I won't let myself be in that position.
I don't think about it when
a person, kid comes up to me,
it just, like, throws a red flag out.
They tell ya, when you go to
group, about the red flags.
So it just throws up a red flag,
so I just, if he says hi
to me, I, "Hi," go on.
But life is very hard when you're banished
as a sex offender, or even
harder as a sex predator,
because once that happens,
you go in a neighborhood
and they tell everybody on that street
that they have a sex
offender living there.
If you go into an apartment building,
they tell everybody in
the apartment building
that there's a sex predator living there.
So you're never away from it.
I have to register four times a year
with the sheriff's department,
and that's no fun because, if you forget,
you go back to prison,
and you've gotta do your
sentence all over again.
Your whole complete sentence.
It's really bad to do a crime,
and especially when a murderer
is not treated like a
sex offender is treated,
and, to me, that's just not right,
but to the world it is.
And I think my mother
sort of screwed my life up
because of the things that happened
while I was laying there.
And when my uncle, supposedly Uncle Joe,
who she was messing with,
would spend the night at our house,
I'd get up in the middle of the night
and try to make it with him in the bed.
I mean, that's all I knew.
I thought that was normal.
- [Mark] You would initiate?
- Yeah, but he'd push me away,
then nothing ever happened.
He never told my mother,
but that's what would
happen when he came over.
- [Mark] And you were how old?
- I was six or seven, about that age.
He was a custodian and he had a room,
it's where he lived,
he had a room down there
with the big boilers.
It was a big building that
he was a custodian in.
I'd say it was about
seven or eight stories,
big, big, brick building and
there were boilers there,
and my mother, that's where she would go
and have sex with him,
and it was a small bed.
It wasn't a big bed,
and I'd be laying right next to my mother,
and they would do the deed,
and then I'd try to do the
deed when he came to the house.
And I guess that's how I got started
with the boys at school.
I would offer them money,
tips from my paper route.
'Til I got caught.
And then we had to move to Florida
'cause my parents were embarrassed,
'cause we have a big
family, we're Italian.
God, my mother had eight
sisters and one, two brothers,
so I had a lot of nephews and nieces
and cousins, and we left.
And nothing happened 'til
I ran into this hustler.
We were called the Clearwater 28
because all 28 of us were
with this one person,
and he got picked up for a B and E
and the police knew that he was hustling
and he was underage,
so that's how we all
got connected with that.
- [Mark] But you're escapade
that you got arrested for,
was that one of, were there others
that you engaged in that
you didn't get caught for?
- Many, many.
- [Mark] How many young boys
do you think you had fun with?
- Oh...
Well, there's an old saying,
as many dicks that were put in me,
if they were sticking out,
I'd look like a porcupine.
That's how many.
And that's no,
none anymore.
The porcupine has died (laughs).
- [Mark] Do you have remorse
over that behavior, or?
- You know...
- [Mark] I mean, you were
six, seven, eight years old
and you were initiating with older men.
- Right.
- [Mark] I mean, maybe
this is a gay culture thing
that I don't understand, it sounds-
- I don't have any, well,
like the judge told me,
with the 13 year old, me
buying him cigarettes.
He was out there, I
didn't give him any money.
I just did it because he was cute,
but he was out there hustling
to get money for his mother's addiction.
That came out in the hearing
and the judge told me
that he wasn't gonna
charge me any restitution
because I paid my restitution,
a carton of cigarettes.
But that's the youngest
boy that I went with
after I was 30, 30 years old.
But between the ages of 13, 14, and 15,
there were young kids from school,
but that all ended when I turned 21
and could get into gay bars.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- Important lesson?
To love myself better.
To mind my own business.
I really, I guess it's because,
I chalk it up as old age.
I guess when you get a certain age,
you just don't care if
you have sex anymore.
I don't even masturbate anymore.
Friends come in and I tell 'em,
"Hey, since I lived where I'm living now,
we moved in in January, I'll
be a year I haven't had sex."
They'll say, "Yeah, we know you."
But I haven't, so it's
just living out my life.
I wanna say, though, I
think about all these,
and I remember all of
them and I think about it.
It never leaves you, you're
always, it's in your mind.
- [Mark] And how are
those memories for you?
Are they pleasant, are they painful?
Do you have guilt over them?
- Some guilt, no pleasantry,
no pleasantry whatsoever.
Not for what I-
- [Mark] Do you feel like
you took advantage of these-
- Yeah, I do, and I did.
Because at the time, they didn't want to,
but you work on them,
like they say that you prime them,
so you get them to where they will do it.
Yeah, I feel terrible
about the whole situation
now that I look back
at it, all those years.
I wasted my life.
I didn't make my life better at all,
and if there's anybody that does this
and is listening to this and seeing this,
heed my warning, it's not worth it.
It really isn't because
you're scarred for life.
And thank God my mother's not living.
- [Mark] You and your victim both.
- Excuse me?
- [Mark] You and your
victim both are scarred.
- Oh, I apologized to my
victim a hundred times over,
and if I could see him,
I would tell him that I am so sorry,
but we're not allowed to have
any contact with our victims.
I wouldn't know where he is anyway.
- [Mark] All right, Frankie,
thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Oh, you're welcome.
- [Mark] Thank you so much.